pese a los incumplimientos en los ceses
al fuego han servido para rebajar las
tensiones hasta ahora
Sí en realidad
se espera Pues que extiendan este si es
al fuego Aunque varios medios también se
han registrado los los enfrentamientos
continúan hay actividad Armada en varios
puntos de del país No solo en la capital
hemos hablado de la mediación de Estados
Unidos y Arabia Saudita Qué papel juegan
estos dos países en el conflicto para
que los actores les reconozcan ese poder
de mediación
sí Estados Unidos tiene un papel
histórico en Sudán también fue parte de
la mediación en la guerra civil con con
el sur de Sudán que llegó a la
independencia
de la creación de la República de Sudán
del sur y el caso de Arabia Saudita
tienen ahí una alianza
que se ha fortalecido en años recientes
debido a que ciudadano apoyó también la
alianza internacional encabezada por
Arabia saudí en el conflicto en yemen
y la división en dos bandos militares en
el país el reflejo también de una
división social que pueda llevar a una
abierta guerra civil o es una lucha por
el poder entre cúpulas de ejército y
paramilitares
es una lucha entre la entre una lucha
por el poder político una lucha entre la
cúpulas militares no entre los militares
y esos grupos paramilitares que se han
fortalecido en estas últimas dos décadas
en Sudán
uno de los puntos clave además de esta
crisis es el control del oro en el país
se puede reducir el conflicto al control
por el oro o hay más factores clave no
hay más factores claves el oro es uno de
ellos por el factor político me parece
que es el central
pero el oro juega un papel también
determinante en el sentido que es el la
principal fuente de financiamiento de
las FARC porque las minas de oro que
están en el este del país están
controladas por muhammad gemetti este
líder de las fuerzas de apoyo rápido